(upbeat music)
- What's up, people?
Michael here to talk about a fellow, bald,
digital media personality
who, unlike yours truly,
has inspired the exquisite
wrath of epidemiologists
and 1970s folk singers alike.
That's right, Mister Joseph James Rogan.
Now, we talked about Rogan's penchant
for peddling vitamins
with sky-high promises
in our video about men's wellness,
so be sure to check that out.
But here's the gist.
Rogan was a stand-up
comedian, turned sitcom star,
turned host of "Fear Factor,"
turned UFC commentator,
who made that rare pivot
into global celebrity
when he started his podcast,
The Joe Rogan Experience in 2009.
It was bought by Spotify in 2020
for a technically-speaking
(beep) ton of money,
and today it's the most
popular pod in the world.
Rogan's devoted fans regularly
tune in to consume episodes
that often last longer than
your average REM cycle.
But lately, Rogan's come under fire
for spreading misinformation about COVID,
interviewing some pretty sus people,
and supplying enough racial slurs
for multiple compilation videos.
In fact, it's starting to
feel like the only person
more fervent than a Joe Rogan
fan is a Joe Rogan hater.
So, what makes Joe Rogan such
a provocative cultural flash point?
Why does this seemingly
normal specimen of a man
inspire equally aggressive
amounts of love and anger?
And ultimately, what
does Rogan's prominence
say about our society?
Let's dig in and find out
in this Wisecrack Edition,
What's the Deal with Joe Rogan?
Now, let's be clear,
we've posed a question
with no easy answer.
Joe Rogan's deal is
innately hard to define.
That's in large part because
there really isn't anyone else
doing what he's doing,
at least at his level
of fame and influence.
Sure, he asks people questions
under the pretext of gathering information
but he doesn't claim to be a journalist.
He talks to experts, but
has never himself claimed
to be an expert on
anything, except maybe porn.
(Joe blows raspberry)
- Woo, got it out of my system.
Now I can concentrate
on my life, my career,
and if I meet somebody
I won't be so needy.
- [Michael] And he might perform standup,
but on the show he doesn't
function as a comedian.
He's unabashedly in search
of genuine discourse
about a range of topics.
(upbeat music continues)
His listeners often say
that they see themselves
reflected in Rogan.
He paints himself as an average dude
who just so happens to
be able to hold his own
in conversation with everyone
from comedians to astrophysicists.
- So philosophy and quantum mechanics,
they sort of...
They share some sort of a border.
- [Michael] Importantly,
Rogan's crafted a platform
for himself that grants
him complete control
over his public image.
And he seems to use it
to intentionally baffle
the mainstream media.
Because Rogan rarely gives interviews,
the only way to understand
him is to actually listen
to his lengthy podcasts.
This gives him a heavily
cultivated outsider status.
That's even as he makes
millions of dollars
off one of the biggest
media companies in the world
and arguably stands as one of
the most influential people in America.
But if Rogan was just
innocuously interviewing
tons of people he probably wouldn't be
instigating this level of controversy.
Though, of course, some
of his guest choices
have been questionable.
♪ Oh sweet baby Jesus we
are live, Gavin McIness ♪
- [Michael] But where
Rogan gets slipperier
than a lubed-up butter
sculpture of a dolphin
is in his actual beliefs.
He has said, "If you say
you disagree with me,
"I probably disagree with me too.
"I disagree with me all the time."
And indeed, his worldview
is inherently impossible
to define or pin down.
His opinions are not even
internally consistent.
Any time someone levies a
critique about his views,
as expressed in one episode,
there seems to always be another episode
where he says the opposite.
It's a powerful tactic that does not work
in other forms of media enterprise.
Typically, ideological
consistency is demanded.
It'd be like if the New
York Times Editorial Board
refuted itself every week.
And because any one of
his controversial opinions
is personally contradicted by him,
he can get away with voicing
just about any viewpoint he wants.
That means he can't
really be held accountable
the way other public figures,
actually striving for
consistency, might be.
For example, Rogan might mock mask-wearing
with comedian Bill Burr.
- I just love how wearing
a mask became this (beep)
soft thing that you were
doing, like being courteous.
Being courteous, why is it for (beep).
- It just is so stupid.
- [Michael] But just a few months earlier,
he hosted epidemiologist
Michael Osterholm,
who issued grave warnings
about the importance
of taking the virus seriously.
- Well first of all you have to understand
the timing of it in the sense
that it's just beginning,
and so in terms of what hurt, pain,
suffering, death, happens so
far is really just beginning.
- [Michael] And then a year
later, he gave a platform
to cardiologist, Peter McCullough,
who claimed that the pandemic was planned
by universities like Johns Hopkins.
- And it seemed to be completely
organized and intentional
in order to create acceptance for,
and then promote mass vaccination.
- [Michael] Oh,
consistency, where art thou?
Anyway, by establishing himself
as an open-minded goofball
who just likes to chat with smart people,
Rogan creates a unique
intellectual liminal zone
in which he and his audience
can just ask questions,
even if those questions
are being posed to and by
some controversial folks.
(upbeat music continues)
Across the political spectrum,
Rogan belies comparison.
With conservatives, like
Ben Shapiro or Alex Jones,
liberals, like the Pod Save America guys,
or leftists, like streamer Hasan Piker,
the agenda being relayed
is always pretty explicit.
In contrast, Rogan has
cultivated a platform of loyal
followers who intrinsically
believe in and trust him,
despite not fully knowing
what his beliefs are.
Perhaps the closest thing we
have today to what Rogan does
is something like "The View,"
where a group of women sit around and chat
about a broad range of topics
they lack expertise on,
but have strong feelings about.
Like Rogan, they'll bring
in experts to learn from,
to lend credibility, and to
hopefully offer the audience
some intellectual value.
But because there isn't
really a "The View" for men,
many fans see Rogan as providing
a masculine-coded space that
doesn't exist elsewhere.
Furthermore, Rogan doesn't
talk down to his audience.
And that's a big deal,
because a lot of Rogan
fans see mainstream media
as being pretty judgy towards
non-mainstream opinions.
But Rogan harbors no judgment
towards his guests or his audience.
Hell, he's got no judgment for anyone!
Come as you are!
In Rogan's universe, everybody
with an opinion is cool,
from Bernie Sanders to a Proud Boy.
The only real sin is not
listening to each other.
And that's what makes Rogan so compelling.
His listeners don't feel like
they're being told what to think.
They see Rogan fostering open dialogue
across the ideological spectrum,
and then having enough
faith in his audience
to draw their own conclusions.
Taken at face value, that sounds great.
If we buy the curated image
that Rogan has crafted
of himself and his podcast,
it actually sounds pretty benign.
Now importantly, because of
Rogan's intellectual flexibility
and willingness to talk to anyone,
many of his listeners describe him
as an outside disruptor
speaking truth to power
and countering mainstream narratives.
This characterization, though,
ignores an important reality,
these days, Joe Rogan is
as mainstream as it gets.
Indeed, each week his
podcasts get more listeners
than any single evening of programming
on a major news network.
(upbeat music continues)
Even as he pitches himself as an outsider,
it's hard to not call him mainstream.
This apparent contradiction was explained
by the New York Times podcast, The Daily,
which posits that there are really
two mainstream medias at play here.
There's what they call the
corporate legacy mainstream,
that is, huge newspapers
like the New York Times or
a television news network.
These organizations are supposedly held
to certain journalistic
standards and practices,
like fact checking, source vetting,
and not spreading misinformation.
In practice, this doesn't
always go perfectly,
but the ideals still stand.
Reporters, editors, legal
teams, and fact checkers
all collaborate to ensure their content
is responsible and unimpeachable.
They are machines with
lots of moving parts
and a lot of money.
This is the establishment mainstream.
And then there's Rogan's
mainstream, a sort of Wild West
where the rules of
journalism no longer apply.
While a skilled interviewer,
Rogan's not beholden to those
same standards of research,
sourcing, fact checking, and so on.
His podcast is informal.
It allows a wide range of viewpoints
without concern for
whether or not those views
are properly backed up by
standards like peer review.
As a result, he's seen as
being anti-establishment,
and allowing those not typically
given a platform to speak.
So Rogan's not journalism.
But he's also not explicitly
trying to entertain
in the usual sense of the word.
Sure, he'll have funny comedians
and actual conspiracy
theorists on his show
but he'll also invite
high-brow intellectuals.
In a world where the line
between entertainment
and journalism has become
increasingly blurry,
Rogan collapses that dichotomy entirely.
And while his fans may see
themselves as pushing back
against the corporate legacy mainstream,
they are very much a part
of Rogan's mainstream,
complete with a huge
voice and a huge platform.
This is no counterculture.
But his mainstream is undoubtedly
pushing back against gatekeeping.
And the experts and intellectuals
that modern journalism relies on
are often considered
to be doing just that.
To understand Rogan's
appeal as the self-defined
common man of the media,
we have to understand
anti-intellectualism
as a force in America.
Now, there's been a long
standing tension in America
between the so-called elite intelligentsia
and the average Joe.
While our earliest
leaders were undoubtedly
the headiest of intellectuals,
men of the mind were met with suspicion
as early as Thomas Jefferson's
presidential run in 1796.
And, in the early 19th century,
as the ideals of populist democracy
came to the forefront of
the American consciousness,
the goal was to eliminate status
differences in public life.
According to historian Richard Hofstadter,
the leagues of common
men wanted to get along
with as little leadership as possible
from the educated and propertied class.
In a country where most people didn't even
have an elementary education,
where could these common
folks look for guidance,
if not to learned scholars?
(upbeat music continues)
Rather than, say, pushing
to expand the realm
of higher education to make it accessible
to the every man, something else happened.
As Hofstadter explains,
"As popular democracy
"gained strength and confidence,
"it reinforced the widespread belief
"in the superiority of inborn,
intuitive, folkish wisdom
"over the cultivated, over sophisticated
"and self-interested knowledge
"of the literati and the well-to-do."
That is to say, the ethos
of 19th century America
was to trust your gut, not a book.
We see touches of this mindset
in some of Rogan's logic-driven,
but ultimately disreputable,
pontificating today.
For example, Rogan once said
something about COVID vaccines
that might first strike you
as relatively intuitive.
- But if you're, like, 21 years old
and you say to me,
"Should I get vaccinated?"
I'll go, No. Are you healthy?
Are you a healthy person?
Like, look, don't do anything stupid
but you should take care of yourself.
If you're a healthy person
and you're exercising all
the time and you're young
and you're eating well,
I don't think you need
to worry about this.
- [Michael] Of course, within
the epidemiological community
there's near-unanimous agreement
that young, healthy people
absolutely should be vaccinated,
because the issue is more complicated
than Rogan's common sense.
That speaks to an inconvenient
reality about our world.
The Venn diagram of intuition and fact
does not always overlap.
Anyway, Rogan addressed the backlash
by essentially abdicating
intellectual responsibility.
But back to history.
Anti-intellectualism in America
was really off to the races
with the rise of Jacksonian
democracy around 1822.
Andrew Jackson's administration
distrusted expertise
and intellectuals, and
basically kick-started
their expulsion from
political life for decades.
Now, as author Tom Nichols
points out in his book,
"The Death of Expertise,"
societies tend to thrive
when people don't have to
rely on their own expertise
in every single arena of life.
Back when everybody had to be
able to hunt their own food
and build their own homes
and make their own clothes
and bind their own wounds,
workmanship was a lot shoddier.
Not having enough time to
devote to knowing one thing
or a small number of things
made our ancestors jacks of
all trades and masters of none.
But for a lot of American history,
this kind of self-reliance
by the uneducated common man
was extolled as virtuous.
At the same time, because
most professions back then
required little or no formal education,
intellectualism was seen more as a luxury
than as a necessity.
The growing world of business
also emphasized intuition
versus over-intellectualizing.
Again, not unlike Joe Rogan.
(upbeat music continues)
But as the world became
increasingly complicated
via the Industrial Revolution,
it also became increasingly difficult
to be functionally self-reliant.
Experts with specific
knowledge were brought back
into the fold of political
life in the Progressive Era
at the end of the 19th century,
where they would basically maintain sway
throughout the New Deal era.
Back then, their priorities
pretty much aligned
with those of the aggrieved common man
who had seen their country hijacked
by the likes of Gilded Age robber barons.
But what really changed everything,
according to Hofstadter,
was the rise of anti-Communist
sentiment in America.
See, a fair amount of public intellectuals
had Communist sympathies and
due to anxieties that climaxed
during the Red Scare of the 1950s,
these experts in everything
from social sciences,
to chemistry, to screenwriting,
were systematically
purged from public life.
Across the board, intellectuals were met
with a suspicion and hostility that,
as Hofstadter noted in 1963,
was still alive and well.
But ironically, at the same time
as hostility towards
intellectuals was resurging,
America began needing
experts more than ever.
As Hofstadter explained
of early 1960s America:
"Society has grown greatly in complexity
"and in involvement with
the rest of the world.
"In most areas of life,
"formal training has become
a prerequisite to success.
"At the same time, the
complexity of modern life
"has steadily whittled away the functions
"the ordinary citizen can intelligently
"and comprehendingly perform for himself."
This only intensified as America
became increasingly oriented
towards knowledge work.
In the complicated
post-Industrial-Revolution world,
we can't all know everything,
so we rely on experts.
An architect to design the building,
an electrician to wire it,
a plumber to make the
toilet work, et cetera.
In situations like this, we understand
that someone who has been
trained and certified
and worked at it for years is
probably the person you want.
Even if, like me, you thought
you could fix your toilet
and then ended up having to number two
at a coffee shop for a week.
(upbeat music continues)
But, as Nichols notes, this isn't the case
when it comes to more
heady, less hands-on work.
Americans, he writes, tend
to really chafe at the idea
that we're not all equally as smart
and capable as the next guy,
especially if we still suspect that guy
might have Communist sympathies.
So even as American resentment
towards intellectuals grew,
we became increasingly reliant on them
in every facet of life,
thus further augmenting that resentment.
Nichols argues that this hostility
is continued into the present day
and we think that's part of
why Rogan is so appealing.
He's not an expert and doesn't try to be.
He embodies an overarching ethos that,
as Hofstadter puts it, "The
plain sense of the common man
"is an altogether adequate substitute for,
"if not actually much superior to,
"formal knowledge and expertise."
And this is an ethos that has
dominated American society
for much of its history.
Now, there's a real psychological reason
why trusting experts
can feel disempowering,
especially as we've
entered the knowledge era,
where hugely complex endeavors,
like sequencing the human genome
or coding self-driving cars
have been accomplished.
It's easy to feel like we know nothing
and that's not a fun feeling.
As Nichols writes, "The fact of the matter
"is that we cannot
function without admitting
"the limits of our knowledge
"and trusting in the expertise of others.
"We sometimes resist this
conclusion because it undermines
"our sense of independence and autonomy.
"This natural human
reaction among individuals
"is dangerous when it becomes
a shared characteristic
"among entire societies."
In other words, it's fair to
hate being wrong about stuff.
The problem is when this becomes
a larger societal mindset.
Because what happens if
nobody's willing to be wrong,
if every opinion holds equal weight,
regardless of its grounding
in facts or reality?
When this becomes a
society's guiding ethos,
we run the risk of dismantling
the very foundations of
knowledge that enable progress.
As Nichols notes, today, "The issue is not
"indifference to established knowledge.
"It's the emergence of
a positive hostility
"to such knowledge.
"It is a new Declaration of Independence.
"No longer do we hold these
truths to be self-evident,
"we hold all truths to be self-evident,
"even the ones that aren't true."
And that's where we run
into trouble with Joe Rogan.
Sure, the guy consults
plenty of reputable experts.
But he also consults people
who have been ostracized
by the scientific community
for spreading misinformation
and extolling science
that hasn't been replicated
or peer reviewed.
He also regularly asks people
their opinion on topics
on which they are not experts
(upbeat music continues)
and probably haven't formed opinions
with the same rigor as someone
with, say, a graduate degree.
So what happens when
this potpourri of voices
is heard on the same platform?
The message becomes implicit.
All of these truths are equally valid.
And when you have some folks
urging people to get vaccines
and some urging you not to,
the collapse of reliable
truths becomes truly dangerous.
Sure, you might choose to take
the expert-certified opinion
that vaccines save lives to heart,
or you might vibe more
with Rogan's implicit logic
that vaccines are an unnecessary
risk for young people.
Or you may favor the doctor
whose unprovable anti-vax views
leave him standing alone
in the medical community.
But when all opinions
are given equal weight,
choosing who to believe
becomes a trickier prospect.
And this is actually made
all the more complicated
by Rogan's personal affect.
He has an almost-childlike
sense of credulity,
often acting as impressed, surprised,
or delighted by someone's opinion.
And sure, Rogan might push back on some of
his most inflammatory guests,
though he does give them plenty of time
to share their opinion.
But overall, he's more interested
in hearing his guests out
than in engaging in rigorous debate,
and this is the root of the problem.
To explain, we need to
look to epistemology,
a branch of philosophy
concerned with investigating
knowledge and human understanding,
or how we know what we know,
and specifically, the
subsection of that branch
called virtue epistemology.
Virtue epistemologists spend a lot of time
thinking about epistemological virtues,
ie, intellectual virtues
or qualities in a person's
character or disposition
that contribute to their
ability to acquire knowledge.
These include traits
like curiosity, humility,
objectivity, and creativity.
Epistemological vices, as
scholar Eric Kramer explains,
are the opposite.
Character traits or thought patterns
that impede or prevent the
acquisition of knowledge.
These include dogmatism,
intellectual dishonesty,
and wishful thinking.
The most important epistemological
vice, for our purposes
is gullibility, or credulity.
Though the term epistemological
vice is somewhat new,
the concept goes way back.
In 1661, philosopher Joseph
Glanvill criticized skepticism
and credulity as equal and opposite vices
toward the obtaining of knowledge.
Of credulity, he described
the human tendency
to make precipitate,
i.e., hasty judgements
when we choose to receive
(upbeat music continues)
all things via promiscuous admission.
Which, coincidentally,
was written about me
on a bathroom stall in college.
Basically, while the skeptic
might choose not to accept
even the most persuasive,
well-formed argument,
the credulous person does the opposite.
Credulity implies a lack of discernment,
and credulous folks
tend to accept knowledge
from the latest person they speak to,
in spite of qualification
or persuasiveness.
It's being promiscuous with your brain,
which, to be clear, is different
than having an emotional affair.
Credulity, like other
epistemological vices,
thus impedes the careful
acquisition of knowledge.
And that's what we think Joe
Rogan's show is probably doing.
By presenting a broad range of voices
of varying degrees of credibility,
without rigorous pushback
or a journalistic reliance
on fact, the show establishes those views
as essentially equally valid.
And we'd argue that Rogan's
much-lauded open-mindedness
falls more in the camp of credulity.
What's more, the way
he exhibits this trait
with nearly every guest
encourages the audience
to similarly lack discernment.
In a way, Joe Rogan's success in America
makes a ton of sense.
He's kind of the contemporary embodiment
of that old American populist tendency
to trust your gut when you hear
something that sounds right
rather than listening
to the annoying expert
who's been studying the topic for years.
These days, it's become
something of a cliche
to say that podcasting
comedians like Rogan
are the new philosophers.
But in Rogan's case, epistemic
credulity is precisely
what makes him not at
all like, say, Socrates,
the first live-action podcaster.
Socrates' built his philosophical wisdom
on self-examination and the acceptance
of one's own ignorance, which meant that
when he had guests,
i.e., Athenian leaders,
on his podcast, i.e., a street corner,
he aimed to push them
through a series of questions
to evaluate the truth of their arguments.
Unlike Socrates, Rogan
seems mostly comfortable
with letting everyone
share their opinions,
with some exceptions, rather
than pushing his guests
and himself towards a deeper
level of self-examination.
So, if you're seeking
philosophical wisdom,
probably stick to YouTube.
But what do you guys think?
Is Joe Rogan's show a beacon
of inquiry and wisdom?
Or is it a bastion of
stoner anti-intellectualism?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
and be sure to check out Patreon
page if you have not before
'cause we are about to unveil
some very cool new features.
Pump up that subscribe button
like you're Rogan's beef-fueled biceps
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music continues)